so for the last year we've told you
what's going on in america's schools
really from kindergarten
all the way into graduate school at
every single level
equity has changed the way kids are
taught and it's changed very much
what they're taught and it's poisoning
them very few parents have fought back
but some are beginning to
here's one in florida a mother called
keisha king
told her school board what this kind of
indoctrination needs to stop immediately
it is sad that we are even contemplating
something like critical race theory
where children will be separated by
their skin color and deemed permanently
oppressors or oppressed in 2021
that is not teaching the truth unless
you believe that whites are better than
blacks
telling my child or any child that they
are in a permanent oppressed
status in america because they are black
is racist
if this continues we will look back and
be responsible for the dismantling
of the greatest country in the world by
reverting to teaching hate
and that race is a determining factor on
where your destiny lies
good for her she's telling the truth too
few are
on the other hand parents have almost no
support but now they do
the 1776 group is a new 1776
project is a political action committee
designed to help school boards
communities elect sane people to run
their schools ryan gordusky is the
president of it we're happy to have him
on now
ryan thanks so much for coming on tell
us what you're doing seems important
so the 1776 project pack it's found on
1776projectpack.com
is going to it's a super pac that anyone
can donate to from around the country
and over the course of this year and
hopefully next year we will be donating
and campaigning on behalf of school
board candidates
who oppose critical race theory being
taught in schools and will be able to
use their position as a school board
member
to hire to buy textbooks that are that
are patriotic and that tell a reasonable
and realistic history
a version of american history that will
be able to push for superintendents that
counter principals and teachers who are
activists
and work to kind of make education sane
again for young children
it's funny so you're basically counter
balancing or trying to what george soros
has been doing for 30 years
you know influencing local elections and
you're and someone's finally doing it
back
thank kevin are you getting a good
response
yeah so i started two weeks ago over 700
people have donated i've gotten
thousands of emails from
both candidates and just parents who
said this is what's happening in my
school and i
and i don't know what to do and i don't
know what to do or how to fight back or
they're said
you know how do i find out what's being
active in my school i think this kind of
dialogue with parents is very very
important
look this is enormously unpopular they
don't want this
radical approach to education being
pushed they don't want this racist
approach
it is critical race theory is
state-sanctioned racism there's no other
word for it it is
against many many different variety of
children for many many different reasons
and i think that it is important that
we're doing this as their own fight back
so there are elections already being
held
we've seen you know anti-critical race
theory school board
candidates winning um and i hope that
you know i could do my part if
these are not a very expensive elections
to run and they're nonpartisan most of
the time
i think that we can really go far and do
a lot um with with
very little and you know it's it's it's
amazing that with all the money
in conservative inc and conservative uh
groups that it took a kid from queens to
sit there and do this but i'm really
proud to
and i hope that we change the way
education is being done well yeah
and it is most people hate this stuff
but most people didn't like the
bolsheviks either and they took over the
entire country for 70 years so it can
happen
so if you're thinking about writing a
check to aei maybe you should pause and
send it to ryan gardeski just a thought
ryan thank you good to see you tonight
thank you